are you breastfeed yes
my name is Colette Wiseman I'm a ER
physician and also a lactation counselor
I go out to new moms houses and help
them with breastfeeding most of its
really just reassuring moms that they're
doing it right and babies getting enough
milk and answering some basic questions
about timing and what's normal in a
newborn I'm here today to assist and
guide two men who are gonna try out mama
breast even though their men are gonna
be simulating what it's like to
breastfeed I feel like I know a decent
amount about breastfeeding I know that
there's a lot of nutrients in the milk I
know that there's actually no age to
ever stop breastfeeding it's just a
societal thing that people will make you
feel like you need to stop drinking
breast milk at a certain age I mean you
can't be like 35 and be like drink some
of that breast milk what I know about
breastfeeding is that it's a necessity
for the baby and I know that it can be
uncomfortable for women because you know
your breasts are large
whoa this is what I'm gonna have to wear
yeah this is gonna simulate
breastfeeding I have to weigh this the
whole day I just throw this up over yep
just goes on should turn off the valve
no leave them on okay they don't leak it
or in those weird on my neck and on my
back if you're going to simulate
expressing milk like if your baby's
having trouble actually latching onto
the breast what you need to do is cup
your hand under the breast not covering
you're not gonna cover that area or
nipple you're gonna cup under kind of in
a C shape and express gently like it's a
water balloon oh yeah you have to hit
that magic spot it's not just a matter
of grabbing and squeezing you're gonna
actually move baby
so that knows is that the nipple and
your baby is gonna move his head back or
her head back and latch on like that I
have to feed a baby every few hours
well after newborns are feet more than
every few hours it's if they're getting
formula they'll usually feed every three
hours but if they're breastfed they
might want to go on every hour that's a
lot to remember but I'm gonna need to do
this and so it begins
I'm actually wearing my blazer the
opposite way because I don't want to
look I kept bringing them up to kind of
relieve my neck of the weight of it and
that's what helped and the ladies next
to me we're cracking up because they're
saying sometimes that's what they do
it is heavy it definitely feels like you
can kind of rest it on some
I do that all the time are they heavy
yeah I've noticed I couldn't get into a
work rhythm every time I would finally
get into a flow of doing whatever I was
doing at work my alarm would go off tell
me I have to breastfeed or I'd have to
you disposed into a cup it's now 3:15
and I have to extract milk two feedings
yes I don't have a problem with somebody
else breastfeeding but I did feel weird
about people looking at me I actually
avoided leaving the studio I was scared
to be stared at I was worried that if my
alarm went off and my baby got hungry
that I would not be in a place that was
private enough to breastfeed
this is wrong to be eating all these
skis even came down so I currently
sitting here boobies out no baby this is
a dark awakening into a future I feel if
I had like a daughter like I don't think
I'd want that but thought of like I'm
hoping I'd do it for her sake cuz I
don't think this is a good look for a
female main yeah I was talking about
earlier
I didn't overly comfortable going home
because I feel like I get anxiety about
just going to the market like I'm like
oh I gotta go to the market then I get
anxious and I'm like I can't imagine
having to then think about breastfeeding
at the market to you know I can't
imagine what that anxiety must be like
for women to just be they can't just go
to the market they have to worry about
feeding somebody and they can't not eat
their baby they have to be baby so this
is already taking me a little bit more
self-conscious and the way that I
imagined
I think this was interesting experience
is something that I had no experience of
like what it's like you know because I'm
obviously not a woman and I was never
opposed to a woman breastfeeding in
public but this just made me feel the
trials tribulations to go there people
don't like seeing boobs for their
function because they are sexualized so
I think that if they can somehow
understand that it's you know maybe it's
a little bit of both like if you like
boobs you like boobs the boobs also do
more they act as more than just
something that turns you on
like they bring life they're a part of a
human being as well I commend women all
the time like you all make things look
easier than they actually are and you
know Big Ups to you you birth life and
then you nurture it like that's girl
power